My default settings, factory settings were just, you know,
pro choice. Um, Republicans are evil.
All they care about is money. You're the good you're the good.
Democrats are nice. They care about pork.
Cool.
We make a lot of inappropriate jokes and I'm, you know,
we were joking on this week. So I'm like, Whoa. Maggie was saying, Oh,
who's going to want to sponsor this show because I said something like I was
joking about, um, how the golden gloves went vegan.
And I was like, I just missed the good old days. Right. You know,
a man could be a man and a woman was in the kitchen and Maggie's like, Jesus,
you can't make even jokes like that because someone will clip that and then say,
see, here is Bridgette with her internalized patriarchy.
Unless you say that everyone from the 1950s was a racist bigot,
homophobe you're canceled.
I, yeah, but is it,
should we just pre cancel because comedy is, I think saying, you know,
I said something that was really,
it's always those off the cuff jokes that you make that are completely
inappropriate.
That I think I said something about Cardi B and we were filming and the
dumpster fire witch. And I said, you know,
she said threatened to go to Nigeria. And I sat up, I was like, ah,
have fun with Boko or I'm. And Maggie and Sam who are in there filming with me,
my, my cousin, Maggie, who's my producing partner.
And Samantha who's also on the team. They'd started dying,
laughing because it's, that's,
what's funny is those things that are off the cuff.
And if you say something like that now,
and you aren't in a position like I'm in, which is, um,
slightly immune to cancel culture,
you will get canceled or you're in risk of getting canceled.
So I think comedy has become a lot more afraid. And then, you know,
the argument that people say is like, cancel culture. Isn't real.
Is that people like Ricky, Jarvis and Dave Chappelle are making jokes. Well,
they're millionaires, they're multimillionaire powerful. So you're just,
you can't use people who are even J K Raleigh.
You can't use billionaires and multimillionaires as examples of people who are,
who are canceled proof because they're canceled. Proved just because they're.
Do you sense though, that people like us, maybe, uh, if,
if Jervais is and Chappelle,
let's say you're doing it at like the air force level that were sort of more of
the foot soldiers in this or something like,
or we're in the tanks on the ground.
And we're offering cover to the average person that is the foot soldier in this
that just wants to be able to work a real job,
but still occasionally say what they think without being mobbed. And we're,
we are actually offering them a little bit of cover. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. I think that people,
people feel confused and there is that sense of,
um, terror that's but also hilarious.
And we were talking about this as well. Dumpster fire,
just how it's you're you're,
it's almost like a defense humor for me as a defense mechanism.
It is for many people.
And that's why inappropriate jokes are funny because you're like
world war three, right guys.
And then the memes come out in the memes are hilarious.
And so people are using humor to try and make sense of a world that's really
crazy. And then you have all these people who are experts. And I always say,
no one knows anything. I mean, even experts, they might know things about,
they might have things to contribute, but no one knows what's going to happen.
So anyone who's telling you like here's,
what's going to happen is really just projecting their own
biases and hopes into the world. But no one is like,
no stir Domus they're not gonna.
So I think people just want to laugh to make sense.
You mentioned your, uh, factory settings, uh,
which I have credited you with.
Thank you. I really appreciate that.
9% Sure. I credited you when I mentioned it in the book, I suddenly,
as I'm saying, and I suddenly afraid that I didn't, but, um,
but let it be known that you were the first person that came up with the phrase
fractory settings that I had ever heard.
Can you just explain what factory settings are?
I know we talked about it last time,
but I think it's such a right way of sort of looking at why everything is so
screwed up or,
or sort of how you would take everything down to first principles to then sort
of look at.
Yeah.
Factory settings is really just the default that you were kind of
installed as a child. For instance,
I was raised in a very liberal family.
It was very East coast. We, I didn't,
I was thinking about the other day, I'm like,
I don't think I even met anyone who was pro-life until I was in my
third on Twitter. Yeah. Maybe. I mean, it might've been,
I just was not exposed to, I didn't. I was in Minnesota,
but we lived in the city. So I was always very much in, and again,
I wasn't really, you know, engaging in the debate club at school.
So I didn't, I had some conservatives in my life,
but my default settings, factory settings were just, you know,
pro choice. Um, Republicans are evil.
All they care about is money. You're the good, you're the good guy.
Democrats are nice. They care about poor people. Do you think so,
do you think that's a personal thing or that generally when I,
when I've used the phrase, maybe this is my own take on it.
I've sort of said to people that the factory settings that we're all given
pretty much, if you grow up in America or, you know, in the last 40 years,
let's say, is that, that is the narrative. So yes, of course,
some people are brought up say Christian conservative and they're brought up
pro-life or whatever, but that's really, that's really an outlier, right?
To the main set of ideas that are sort of accepted out of the gate,
which are Democrats, good Republicans, bad Democrats for poor people,
Republicans for rich people, Democrats, you know, all of that kind of stuff.
It depends on where you grow up because I think everyone's factory settings are
different and that, and it depends on your region.
So if I was raised in, you know, somewhere in the South, perhaps,
or in Texas or in a different family than perhaps I would have different
factory settings, um, my very good friend is,
was raised conservative. And he was raised to think all liberals are right
and lefties and that they,
you know, can't, can't argue any of their own points. They, they,
so he,
he just won't even really engage in a leftist debate because he,
he thinks that that was the way he was raised by his family that was
conservative,
but it was also known that they were not the mainstream
point of view or right.
That set of ideas.
Wasn't the thing coming down to you from Hollywood and the media all the time.
Right.
And to kind of keep those ideas somewhat on the down low.
So even in graduate school, he had to,
he's had to kind of pretend just fake,
go along with a lot of the crazy stuff that he's seen and
just because he wants to kind of swim through and get done and,
and be done with it. But, so I think that's interesting too.
I don't know. I I've, I've been,
it's been interesting hearing from as many conservatives as I have in the past
couple of years, their own struggles at colleges and how they're kind of these,
you know, they're outliers really in the culture. And I didn't,
I never knew that cause it was just like, whatever. Give me the weed.
For a second though, because that is relative to all this,
for people that don't know you or didn't see our first interview,
you're a former addict,
which I think in a lot of ways seems to set up sort of your view on all of this,
that this isn't, that the culture war for as important as it is. Right.
And this is what we do every day.
And I do believe that this fight is the fight for Western
values and all of these things like it is important,
but that you've already lived through like your own existential
battle for existence. Right.
I feel like that, you know, I grew up in a kind of crazy household too.
So I think there are a lot of people probably like me who grew
up in dysfunctional homes where the culture as it's gotten
increasingly more crazy,
I'm like that meme of the little dog drinking coffee,
like this is fine while everything's on fire,
because that was what I was used to. So the culture is finally reflecting.
I go,
um, but I, I think, uh, the existential crisis,
the first time I had it was 19. I, you know, let's be clear,
I'm still an addict.
I'm a retired. Yeah, no, I still,
that's still there. I can do anything. Addictively even if it's good for me.
And I have, I do have like a, a crazy, you know,
I get fixated on things and obsessed with them.
Twitter is a great example. I have a hard time. People are always like,
how do I get on Twitter? What do I do? I don't know what to tell them,
because I love Twitter. I was like, I need to put myself away.
So I take some breaks too. I do. And I have,
I have a pretty healthy relationship to social media for the most part,
but I think it's about to get healthier. We're going to talk about my,
my,
I think what being in recovery has done for me during all of this
craziness and I have,
I just celebrated six years of sobriety in October. Um,
it,
I can't personally be an anger or resentment because it
puts my sobriety in danger. So I can't live with that stuff.
So I quickly have to figure out how to come into acceptance.
We're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about comedy instead
of the nonstop yelling you get everywhere else, check out our comedy playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.